[Music]
some people may underestimate kids
because of their age but kids are
actually many geniuses
stay tuned to see how a group of teens
is actually saving lives
don't forget to give this video a big
thumbs up and subscribe to the things
for more great content
like this makin bacon do you love bacon
of course you do it's absolutely
delicious but for most of us
bacon hasn't made us any money that's
not true for abby fleck
when she was eight years old she and her
dad were making bacon when they realized
they didn't have any paper towels around
to soak up the grease
abby then had an idea that they could
hang the bacon up while it cooked
and that way the fat and grease would
drip off so a few years later
abby and her dad invented the makin
bacon which is a microwave
safe platter that has three bars that
you can hang bacon on
while it cooks the dish is now sold at
walmart kmart
and target trampoline trampolines are
pretty much the best invention that
there ever was
they are so much fun and the perfect
entertainment for any day
well did you know that the trampoline
wasn't invented by an adult
in 1930 a 16 year old named george
neeson
came up with the idea for the trampoline
he got the idea after watching trapeze
artists
doing their routines and then falling
into safety nets he thought that maybe
would be more exciting if the artist
could somehow keep bouncing he created
the first trampoline in his parents
garage
he continued to work on it while he was
at school at the university of iowa
from there the rest is history
underwater walkie
have you ever been swimming underwater
in a pool or in a sea and wanted to say
something to the person next to you
well in 1996 richie stakowski was
surfing with his dad
he said that when he was under the water
he saw so many pretty things that he
wanted to talk to his dad about it but
there was no way to communicate
underwater so he invented the water
talkie the water taki is a tool with a
blow bow and a plastic membrane that
lets swimmers talk to each other
up to 15 feet away he fits the idea to
toys r us
and they ordered the products from him
keep those wrists warm
playing in the snow is fun but let's
face it it's super
cold there are gloves to keep your hands
warm but up until catherine gregory
there was nothing out there to keep your
wrists warm
in 1994 catherine was 10 years old and
super tired of playing in the snow with
cold wrists
so she invented wristies wristies are
fuzzy sleeves that people can wear
underneath their coats and gloves she
tested the wristies out on her girl
scout troupe before going on qvc
she then became the youngest person to
sell a product on qvc
isn't that crazy all because she
couldn't stand having cold wrists
cool treat popsicles are pretty much a
staple at every pool or
summer event but that wasn't always the
case can you imagine a time before
popsicles
in 1905 the temperature in san francisco
had reached an all-time low
frank epperson had mixed soda water
powder and water in a glass and
accidentally
left a stirring stick in the mixture
when he went to bed after it sat out in
the cold all night it froze over
so frank had unknowingly invented the
first popsicle at just 11 years old
initially frank didn't do anything with
his invention but in 1922
he ended up giving out the treat at a
fireman's ball and
everyone loved it crayon sleeves
coloring with crayons can be fun from
time to time but the problem is every
time we go to use crayons it seems like
half of the pack is broken
cassidy goldstein was experiencing this
too and was super annoyed by it
so when she was 11 she started looking
through her arts and craft supplies
until she found
a plastic tube that was initially
intended to keep roses fresh when they
were shipped she put the crayon into the
tube and made her first version of
crayon holders
in 2006 she was named youth inventor of
the year
by intellectual property owners
education foundation
the money that cassidy earns from her
invention helped cover most of the
college expenses
and even helped her to get an apartment
in new york city when she graduated
magnetic paper putting up wallpaper is
usually a seriously long
seriously boring process but in 2006
sarah buckle decided that she wanted to
be able to decorate her school locker
without having to go through the process
of putting on wallpaper she also hated
the idea of having to take the wallpaper
down at the end of the year
when she finished eighth grade her
father became the ceo
at magnacard so sarah gave her dad her
idea and asked him to make magnetic
wallpaper
her dad loved the idea and they got to
work now the magnetic wallpaper is sold
at target
rite aid and staples man candles a lot
of people think that candles are for
girls with scents named after flowers
and sunny days
so in 2010 13 year old hartmane was
making fun of the candles that his
sister was giving out for her school
fundraiser he then got the idea to make
more manly sense
so he used the money he made from his
newspaper route and thus
man can candles were born the candles
came in scents like coffee
new mint and fresh cut grass just two
years after inventing the candles
hart had so much business that he had to
rent a warehouse and employ
five people babysaver lately in the news
there have been a lot of reports of
parents leaving their babies in the car
sometimes the parent is busy and forgets
the baby is even in there
unfortunately in the summer babies
cannot survive sitting in hot cars for
long periods of time
so andrew pelham invented a device to
stop this from happening
it's called easy baby saver and it's
made of rubber bands and duct tape it
stretches across the driver's side door
and reminds parents that their kids are
in the car
any time they try to open the door he
entered the invention into the rubber
band contest
for young inventors and won second place
smart will
distracted drivers aren't good for
anyone to combat this
a team of teenagers came up with an
amazing device
together tj everts jayden evarts and
brayton everetts invented the smart
wheel device which clips onto the wheel
of a car
the device uses sensing technology to
let drivers know when they are
distracted
it also has an app that can track
drivers driving habits and let them know
when their driving has improved isn't
that the coolest thing
we bet it will save a lot of lives can
you imagine a world without distracted
drivers that's definitely a future that
we would love to live in
that's it for 10 genius kid inventions
that will blow you away
were you shocked by some of these
inventions let us know in the comments
see you next time